Speaker 1: One last quick story here on Trump.
Donald Trump is now begging the Supreme Court,
please hide my taxes. Please, please hide my
taxes for someone who has nothing to hide. I
have never seen anyone go through this amount
of trouble to prevent their taxes from going
public. CNN reporting. Former President
Donald Trump has asked the Supreme Court
to put on hold the release of his tax returns
by the IRS to a Democratic led House committee.
Trump filed the emergency request Monday with
the High Court after a federal appeals court,
as I told you, cleared the way last week for
Trump's returns to be disclosed to the House
Ways and Means Committee. The case is the most
direct way for the House to get Trump's federal
tax returns after trying other avenues for years.
The Trump team wants the Supreme Court to put the
release of the tax returns on pause while the
justices consider whether to take the case up
to review the lower court decision.
This is this is the last salvo.
This really is the last salvo as far as every
legal analyst I've spoken to has told me.
An appeals court has already ruled. Asking
the Supreme Court to look at it is the 100%
last chance. If they don't take it up, then
the Democratic House Committee gets Trump's
tax returns. Do they probably leak from there? I
don't know. Maybe they do. I would never encourage
anybody to do anything illegal. And if they were
to leak, I would absolutely look at them. That's
where I will put it. So this is Trump desperately
begging the Supreme Court to save him. What do we
believe at this point would be in those documents?
Well, I don't think it has changed. Number one,
the documents might reveal Donald Trump is not
as wealthy as he claims to be. At this point,
we know that. So I don't think that that would
be a big surprise. Number two, they might reveal
income sources that are inconvenient or probably
problematic for Trump. What specifically they
would be is the stuff of speculation. And number
three, they might further confirm another thing we
already know, which is Trump uses very different
values for assets depending on what his objective
is, all things we suspect. But it would be
confirmation. We have a great bonus show for
you today. We will talk a little bit more about
Kanye West, who is now suspended from Instagram
for anti-Semitic comments. The high school
football coach who led the prayers on the field
is getting his job back. And we do it every
year. We will again rant and rave about daylight
saving time. It is not a settled issue. It is
very much not a settled issue. All of those
stories and more on today's bonus show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is back.
Speaker 1: The money is being made
and everybody here is good. You can sign up
at join talk mint.com. I will see you there.